what's up everybody watching Fandango
movie clips I am Kristian harloff and I
am about to geek out even harder than I
did yesterday when the force awakens the
latest trailer came out I'm gonna do a
little breakdown a little breakdown
maybe some things that we missed or
maybe some things that the hardcore Star
Wars fans picked up right away and we
want to figure out what exactly is going
on a little speculation a little
analysis of the trailer if you will it's
gonna be a lot of fun because I have
been watching this thing this is
probably the 1347 time I've watched us
let's get into it right off the bat what
I really thought was amazing about this
trailer was the focus on Rey right away
you know that she's the rumors of her
being a scavenger and here she is in the
super stardestroyer
and it's just you see the right there by
the way that shot of her as she's about
to enter and there's that staff that
staff is becoming almost like a
character in the movie you you see is
that there are rumors that is it darth
plagueis is staff if you don't know
Darth Plagueis is go back and watch
Revenge of the Sith
Palpatine explains it pretty thoroughly
but the shot of her in the super
stardestroyer here just the mass of how
big this particular ship was and her
being all by herself alone that shot and
then we we now have by the way
confirmation that Maz Kanata the
character played by Lupita Nyong'o says
who are you and she says I'm nobody
which I don't believe is true I think
she's Luke Skywalker's daughter more on
that later
um so yes she's in she's in the Star
Destroyer she's walking then as that
shot of her just walking with bb-8 alone
and it's very reminiscent to Luke in
Episode four by herself on this planet
and then she looks up and sees this ship
and it's like I think that is this is
JJ's way subtly of telling us this is
her story this is Luke this is this is
the protagonist of the story some
thought maybe it was boyega or fin but
this is this is absolutely Daisy really
raised story she looks up the little
crying smile and the Lucasfilm logo
plays in what a brilliant way to start
the trailer and then there's that shot
of this figure we've seen it in the
International trailers when it first
came out and he's overlooking it this is
the
new Palpatine we think and I'm just
think that this is Snoke I really this
is Andy Serkis a character we haven't
seen a full close-up shot I know some
people maybe thought that it was that it
was Donald Leeson's character but I said
hawks but I see phasma in the back I
believe Huck's is with her but it's um
when over that's between him and Luke
we're both we haven't seen anything from
these two so I can't wait till we
finally see him now here's Brega here's
Finn we I thought the most interesting
line was the fact that he was since he
was younger he was born to do this now
he has nothing to fight for that may
that makes so much more sense now how
he's able to hold the lightsaber and
like it almost reminded me of like the
John Claude Van Damme movie Universal
Soldier that's right I made a universal
soldier reference with Star Wars and I
think that he is trained like this
warrior that is set off into motion he's
almost like as what c-3po and r2d2 did
to start the events of the Star Wars
trilogy that we know and love this I
think is what Finn Finn's purpose is
gonna be he is the one who's coming to I
think
snap ray into motion because you see him
overlooking Jack who there and there's
that he sees the village of where we're
gonna see Finn ah absolutely ray then
you go here's our here's our new Darth
Vader kylo Ren watching this beam they
see this beam in the background and
we're assuming that this is going to be
this new super weapon that we're hearing
of the the planet that has been
conformed has been changed into a super
weapon and then the voice-over the
creepy voice of Adam driver talking
about how he's gonna finish what Vader
started or is that a little bit of a
ruse is JJ Abrams really is he talking
to Snoke there about finish what you
started I think it's probably Vader but
don't be surprised if he's talking to
Snoke as well then is that shot of Vader
you hear the breathing and then the
torture scene with kylo Ren just looking
at Poe and that this is why you get
someone like Oscar Isaac look at the
fear in his eyes and I think what it is
almost like putting a vision in because
the next shot you see is that same beam
destroying a planet destroying a star
system and it's the debt this is why
this movie is not going to be PG by the
way it's cut it's absolutely when we
beat pg-13 because I think there's gonna
be a lot of dark images combining
episode
for an episode 5 into 1 tone the next
shot of the Millennium Falcon and you
hear Princess Leia's theme and the TIE
fighters are going after the ship it's
classic Star Wars cut right into that
shot of Han Solo looking at and talking
to and explaining he is now the guy the
guy that did that thought it was a hokey
religion is now explaining how the force
is indeed real that Jedi are real and
that shot of the Millennium Falcon er I
don't know if any of you guys are the
Knights of O Republic fans but there was
a ship that then called the ebon Hawk
which is very similar to the Millennium
Falcon and they had the grid of the
planets that you can look at and it's
interesting it looks like they have
taken i deceived as rey and finn are
looking at han there's that grid and a
bunch of different planets there it
looks like they're combining a lot of
the mythology from past legends material
or this expanding universe this is my
favorite shot of the trailer the Knights
of Ren standing around a bunch of dead
bodies something went down here and this
is what I always kind of wanted to see
in a Star Wars film it's like Lord of
the Rings meets Star Wars it's a very
medieval they're all standing around it
and only one of them has a lightsaber or
and it's kylo Ren we assume it's the
same saber we've seen and then the
Knights are red behind him these guys
look like they are going to be brutal
and I actually think that there's rumors
that rumors would confirm that the
actors from the raid and the Rey two are
in this film you make them the Knights
of Ren right you would assume so if this
look these guys look devastating who's
gonna be able to fight them then the
shot that we've seen for the kind of
combined of the of the first trailer of
the x-ray is coming in and then that
shot of the stormtroopers waiting for
the attack from the nothing excuse me
the yeah that's my so the X ones are
coming in and then it says at full full
battle very reminiscent to Episode four
that shot now of Poe putting his hand on
Finn's shoulder like there's some kind
of history there already it looks like
from the shots that we've seen that that
finn is wearing Poe's jacket now which
is he doesn't seem to be mine x is a
little kind of a nod and a smile to him
like it's got we're gonna do this but
finn has this look on his face like he
still doesn't know if we should trust
this guy
yet but he's ready to go to battle and I
love that shot you pause on Finn's face
there in the background you see the
Millennium Falcon it's there we don't
know who's piloting it but it's there in
the background and it just goes to show
you that we're going to get the classic
Star Wars battles that we've wanted in
space on planets it is a this is what
you're able to do now in 2015 with the
with the special effects and with the
budget and not over CGI yet making it
look like we're back in the Star Wars
universe okay this shot this is the shot
now some people may or may not have
noticed this but when Han is walking
through this temple or whatever this
might be here and this red droid and
finn looks the right look up to the top
here and it's almost shaded that is a
Mandalorian flag Mandalorian of course
being the race of people that will
defect is from and what is this temple
where they going is this where Maz
Kanata lives is this where Hans taking
them has hot obviously is leaving them
there
great shot one of my favorite shots in
the trailer moving on this shot by the
way this was what was so we saw this in
the the trailer that JJ debuted at
celebration with the hooded figure
putting his hand on r2d2 I am convinced
that this is a flashback and that's
young that's Luke I think that that is
going to be a reveal that that's Luke
and we're gonna see this JJ likes
flashbacks and don't be surprised if
that turns out to be young Luke you know
flashback uh Captain phasma menacing the
way that she carries herself that
walking you want to see who she is going
to who's gonna who has the higher rank
is it her is it kylo Ren because
directly after she's walking through
with that confidence you have kylo ren's
throwing down the hammer with that with
the cross saber and then the next shot
is Daisy Ridley Rey crying if you pause
that shot and on the right hand side
there looks to be a little fur popping
up it almost like the ammo clip of
Chewbacca now I don't necessarily think
that means shabak is gonna die but I do
think that that's true Baca laying there
and because it what about the skin there
that's her hand um I think that you Baca
gets hit and it's in the ice planet it
seems to be that same battle about what
we're about to see here and this shot of
Han and Chewie standing next to me they
look like they've been rescued by
somebody and because they have their
hands up and it's kind of a bunch of
Return of the Jedi when it looks like
they're they're captured and the Chewie
shows up and rescues them it looks like
we're gonna have a moment like that here
could be ready that saves them could be
Poe it looks like that's the same this
the same big battle that we saw on the
net not the ice planet got a different
planet now we cut to the ice planet here
and look at this this is that big Ridge
that all the Thai fighters are hovering
over and the X ones are going after them
what we assume is from what we saw on
that poster that this is the converted
weapon this is gonna be phenomenal
hoping when they explain how they
converted a planet into a weapon that's
how you one up the Death Star we can't
do a third Death Star and we can't do
this another bigger weapon now someone
says they converted a planet into a
weapon okay I'm on board here and I
think then what if it's hot it could be
hot thirty years later would make a lot
of sense and you just just if I think
what you'd get from all these shots of
stormtroopers and an even that shot of
ray firing back this is finally it
almost goes back to what Gareth Edwards
was saying when he was talking about
rogue one the movies called Star Wars
this the last couple of clips in this
trailer makes you feel this is a war
Star Wars this disturbs we were getting
shot in the shoulder by an x-wing kylo
Ren causing havoc on it with with that
shot that we saw from the celebration
trailer and then just more explosions
now this shot here of Princess Leia and
Han I don't think they are together
anymore I think that this is a this this
is one thing that Leia had well one
thing han was able to do with Leia was
that bring out that vulnerability you
see it there because if she's gonna be
whether it's queen or high up in the
command something happens there again
they reunite but I don't think they're
together we'll see now the last shot of
the
well I mentioned earlier that I think
that boyega fan has been trained somehow
because he's holding that lightsaber but
like someone who knows what they're
doing with it I think if you go back to
the Ralph McQuarrie art the original art
from the original trilogy there were
stormtroopers holding lightsabers
they've been using a lot of art from a
quarry whether it be in the rebel series
and now you have John boyega I keep
saying his name but I have to Finn is
holding the lightsaber with a grip and
then here comes the kylo Ren no helmet
on by the way and although I don't care
how trained he is he looks terrified
Finn looks terrified as kylo Ren comes
in throws down the hammer and that's our
trailer now in that shot as well you you
also have as far as embracing the force
knowing that the forces is calling to
you this is goes with the entire theme
of the force awakens I still believe
that Maz Kanata is narrating the entire
trailer we haven't seen her character
yet we might have seen her in the poster
he'll be confirmed later on but there's
so many little things that were picked
up in this trailer that told the story
without having to spoil the story that's
my breakdown right now that's those are
the things that I was able to find while
looking at the trailer very curious what
you guys saw comment below and let me
know are the things that I missed are
the things that you think will happen I
actually really like the fact that Luke
wasn't in it I think it is these this
movie's gonna be the search for Luke how
do you guys feel about it do you wish
you would have seen a little of him are
you okay with not seeing him tell me
some of your theories and your
speculations in the comments below and
make sure if you haven't already
subscribe to this channel this is the
place you find your movie trailers do it
thank you very much I'm gonna go watch
this trailer again